And see dental in my discussion sessions,
people got too excited about charisma.
So we did speak a lot about galleys.
Ba I asked your patients recover
some of the same grounds,
but I hope I can give you a
new jokes about charisma. Uh,
this is one of the most exciting features
of the labor theory and probably run
off next to the Protestant ethic,
right,
the wrong and entered the common
language more than anything else, right?
That we all talk about get asthma and
the people's getting smart charismatic
leaders all the time,
just like the Protestant vert that date
be entered to the popular vocabulary and
everybody who has not tried
any vapor still uses the term.
Uh,
uh,
it's also very important to come to
terms with the idea of charisma because,
uh, uh, a neighbor was a suspected, uh,
uh, in the 1930s, forties and 50s,
to be actually a protocol fascist and
with the idea of charisma advocating a,
for a strong leadership for Germany,
calling for a charismatic
leader for Germany and in Ebay,
almost demanding out of
Hitler. Now, of course,
he died in 1920. He could
not do that. Uh, about,
uh, especially, um, at a
philosopher George wrote clutch.
I accused him to be an
irrational, just, uh,
and, uh, uh, being a portal fascist,
laying the ideology for a
narcissism and add of Hitler.
Uh,
I have to tell you that I
am not absolutely certain
what the Labor would have
done in 1930 or 33.
I hope for a,
like his brother who would not have
gone for the fascists or Nazis.
Um,
but it's complicated.
Ivo tried to make a case that in fact,
the concept of charisma is
not quite what I'd have.
Hitler was. Um, so, um, uh,
the main major themes of the
presentation today. First of all,
we will dov the definition of charisma.
Um,
what is Gary's magical
authority? Uh, then we've,
you're talking about the sources of
charisma very carries mice coming from,
and this is particularly important,
uh,
to see why vapor is actually
not a plot on assay.
Um, uh, then the viewer will be talking
about, uh, uh, uh, the followers,
the charismatic leader. Um,
then we will talk about,
get his Ma as a revolutionary force,
get his Ma as, uh, the,
uh, vehicle of change.
Um,
and I think this is an interesting idea
in Bieber or one of the Vika points,
I think, or fever dearly. Um, I think, uh,
Karl Marx,
uh,
has a much more coherent and much more
best ways if tivity about historical
change as class Tragal,
you know,
and the contradictions between forces
and relations of production. Um,
this is, uh, uh, uh,
historically invalidated,
but a very coherent and very
best soil as it kind of argument.
Vaporous idea of charisma
is that evolution on force
actually has an bitty car,
um, irrelevance, but, uh, it's, uh,
it had an aunt pass swears even
love your Clark about this. Um,
and then become to a big
club with the cat is a smart,
how charismatic leadership
can be routinized or
transmitted from a charismatic
leader to the next.
Uh,
and what I do maquettes of succession
for that charismatic leader.
Uh, so I mean, those of you who've
heard in my discussion section,
as you can see,
it feel not to be just a
regurgitation of the, uh, uh,
um, um, discussion sessions.
And I don't know what happened in
other discussions sections. Also,
the charisma may have come up.
This makes people move. Uh, um, uh,
uh, mine's mine. Smooth equity deal.
So I just a step back a minute and again,
revisit the idea of different types of
domination and what [inaudible] and a,
this is the simplest scheme. I can come
up fit, but I think this is a good one.
Uh, I copyright it. I did it. Uh,
so the question is about,
is OBD as youtube.
It can be you two rules in person or
rules or it can be useful to a person or
master to an individual.
That's the big story, right?
And if it is youth too loose,
that's when we are talking
about legal national authority.
And this will be the topic,
uh, and bureaucratic rule,
a modern liberal democratic
system where a mother,
not that democratic system, but
systems which don't steal, do,
have, um, uh, rules. Um, uh, of, uh, uh,
uh, our floor, uh,
that aren't actually a authoritarian
systems and, you know, operate,
uh, uh, that, uh, uh, uh, uh,
rules of law that authoritarian leaders
actually themselves for all the law and
take law seriously and
implement laws, uh, seriously,
uh,
that lead got national authority,
does not mean liberal democracy.
It simply means that this
is a system in the village.
There is a, um, uh, at all or flaw,
even if the leader itself can
be not particularly democratic,
then we'll classier democracy
as we understand the try.
There's a very recent phenomenon,
a universal suffrage in the western
world became why spread since the 1920s.
And it really became the
dominant form right, of them, uh,
of, uh, uh, political
rule a much, much later.
And I would say more like
after the Second World War, um,
I'm in Switzerland for instance,
you have rights, uh, for women.
Two wars just very recently.
So, well, you know,
democracy is a liberal,
democracy is a very new intervention lit
and the Legal National Authority is not
such a new invention. Uh,
there was a rule of law, um,
in England moving back to,
uh,
the odd ocean evolution, right? This
is going back to the late, um, uh,
uh, uh, uh,
17th century, um, that it
was doable off law, uh,
in the United States. Uh, uh,
before the late 1800
[inaudible] 19th century,
though, there was no liberal democracy
as we understand that, right?
There was no universal suffrage at
all. I saw, I mean, you could have a,
uh, a rule of law. We saw democracy,
but that's still very different from
a system very well be and master.
And that are two ways. How
you are the master, Eh,
you will obey because the tradition and
pointed that master and that's what they
were talking about,
uh,
Tuesday or because the master is believed
to have some charismatic features.
Uh,
I also mentioned it last time that the
difference is between the three types of
authority, legal, rational
authority, traditional authority.
It d and charismatic authority
do not have the same,
I use the term ontological
status. All right? Um,
the two big forms in history,
our traditional authority,
which through rationalization eventually
become Sligo national authority and
charismatic will quality usually
is a transitory pays stage.
Uh, charismatic leader quality
is the charismatic leaders.
Emerge is a,
in times of great times of great need,
desperation and need for change.
And charismatic leaders if they deliver,
you know, as long as they deliver,
they remain leaders.
If they stopped delivering,
cat is my cat is my
steak and away from them.
And it's extremely difficult for
charismatic leader to establish an ongoing
system of charismatic
authority, right? Because, uh,
um,
uh,
it would be very difficult to transfer
that own personal or charisma to somebody
else, right. And to keep
running a charismatic system.
Okay. So that's about generally, you
know, what it is, get it as smart
as I said, this really, we keep
using the term all the time.
The last 18 months, we use it a lot, uh,
because of a candidate and
later President Obama, and,
uh,
there is probably nobody in this
room who at one point the Nafe say,
uh, something about Obama
scaries Ma or you know,
if you did not like him, the
lack of his charisma, right? Uh,
but uh, you know, this was
a gum on, they use sturm.
Now this is coming from vapor because
he did this germ out from at a rather
obscure. They are logical
language. I charism.
I actually refer to some super
human qualities of individual laws.
I would say almost semi guards
who have some very personnel,
an exclusive relationship to God.
And therefore,
like any other human beings,
they kind of can't talk to God and then
they can interpret God's revealed to the
people,
these very charismatic leaders.
So in the most classical
definition of charisma,
Murray first ride that to the great
founders of great world religions,
that's what charisma
in initial meaning men.
Uh, so Muhammad Morzas, uh,
or Jesus,
uh,
the headgear is smart because
they had a special access to God,
right? Um, Moses, God,
the two tables from God,
he could not see the face of God,
but nevertheless,
the God that through Deimos won't God,
nobody else could walk up,
ride that on the mountain and
get these tables, you know,
and are people, this is the law, right?
Because only Moses who good,
right?
And Jesus had a very specific
relationship to God, right?
Christian believe was even the son of God,
embodiment of God.
And undoubtedly,
you know,
it is believed by Christians
that Jesus could actually, um,
uh,
convey to us what God wants us to do.
Right at this very special,
unique, charismatic,
the Epi and Mohamed, uh, had
the special appeal, uh, to,
to God,
or if you are more and more than Mr.
Smiths had these very unique right
relationship to God, right? At one point,
an angel came,
you know that a new sacred book,
a continuation of the Bible,
left it with Mr. Smith.
He translated it. And when the
transition was, God, you know,
the angel came and took it
away that this was a charisma.
Write a very specific superhuman.
It did not happen to any other
human being. Only two Smith, right?
That's uh, um, uh, that is the
initial notion of the meaning.
But now they were very city,
a little,
kind of a broader conception.
And he said all that charisma will
be applied to a certain quality of an
individual. Personalities, important,
still an individual with
considered extra or the metric,
um,
uh,
and treated as endowed with super natural,
super human.
The sounds like the original definition,
but then he was on and he said,
or at least exceptional
powers and qualities, right?
And these are the guarded
as of divine origin.
That's the founders of the
Greek religion or exemplary.
He modifies, tried. It
can be just exemplary.
You don't have to believe that this
is Sammy God or the embodiment of God.
You only have to believe that this
is an excellent blurry being, uh, uh,
who has some exceptional he abilities,
exceptional qualities,
um,
and that will qualify
that uveal call somebody.
Uh,
attached is matic Burson
or the charismatic leader.
Uh, uh, let me also underline
one more term from these, uh,
um, uh, quotation, which
is extremely important. Um,
but,
uh,
he said the person is considered to be
extra ordinary and three teeth as endowed
with super human or an example
of the features. So in,
I think what is extremely important to
see that we bear does not tell us that
this individual is actually extra
ordinary that is actually super human in a
way.
It is in the eye of the beholder.
It is among the followers who at
[inaudible] tried to these qualities to
somebody.
So in ave a charismatic leaders
are being made by the followers,
uh, well what is, uh,
what is the source of charisma?
This is now making it even
more clear and more precise.
It dressed in recognition.
You have to recognize it.
Charisma.
So the relationship of charisma is in the
interpersonal relationship between the
leaders and the followers.
And in this interaction is
charisma being created, right?
It is not given by the grace of Lord,
right?
To an individual person.
It is created by, uh, uh,
doors who are subjected to authority,
right?
And it's also important that the cat is,
uh,
those who follow the charismatic leaders
are usually scenes as followers or
disciples.
Right.
They have some extra ordinary
commitment to this ledger,
right? Um, uh,
these leader creates excitement
in them and these excitement,
but creates a,
uh,
the community of the followers or
the community of the disciples,
right? Um, uh, well, uh,
this is was one of the
reasons why, um, uh,
many people in the last 18
months, uh, regarding the, uh,
uh,
Barack Obama as a charismatic leader
because he was keepable to appearing in a
crowd and moved a crowd,
right?
Create excitement in the crowd,
He created followers, right? You know,
almost one would say
disciples, uh, um, uh,
such a, now what the
charisma can be, we drove,
this is again, a very important
idea and vapor. He said,
if the proof of success allude
the leader for too long,
it is likely that the charismatic
authority will disappear, right?
So the charismatic leader gives you
right promises that it will produce
miracles.
And when the charismatic leader
does not producing these miracles,
right, he must work
mirror. Cause I said, um,
uh, vapor. Then the people we drew,
the recognition of charisma from the
leader and the masters simply becomes a
private person at an
ordinary person loses its,
uh, in the vigil at Pr. Well,
uh, what is, uh, uh, very
important, right? Uh,
so that, uh, uh,
the cat is matic leader has to
promise you miracles, right?
Has to promise you that it will deliver
something but you desperately need,
right?
Get is my,
is deeply rooted in the conditions in
the situation in which charismatic leader
is being constructed by the followers.
When you are in a desperate need,
then you are looking for
a charismatic leader,
which can solve this problem,
but you think is almost unresolvable
then the charismatic leader of your calm
and your promise, you
that this problem, uh,
that the charismatic leader will be able
to solve because it's extra ordinary
characteristics. Um, and again,
if I can come back to the last
elections that was, you know,
clearly, uh, the case, uh, um, uh, uh,
the v how a candidate Obama was,
keep her two of them,
the elections.
You remember one of the
key words, right? Uh,
cataract, Chad eyes. The campaign, um, uh,
haul change. Yes, we can.
I mean, these are very typical elements
that I had to have a charismatic appeal,
right? You are in need. You want hope.
You want to have businesses,
not usual.
You want to live a new type of business.
Now, this is what I promise you, right?
A change and hope and I empower you.
I'm the person who can empower you,
right?
It can be done right.
We can do it right? Yes.
It can be done. Who
Change? Yes. Can Be done.
These are very typical elements,
right? What a charismatic leader,
dusk produce. Um, in recent history,
other charismatic leaders,
which are probably not as attractive,
uh,
in historical perspective as Obama did,
became charismatic leader.
The same way Fidel Castro established
Kelly's is my Ford himself.
The Cuban society was in desperate need
for change in 1960 and Fidel Castro
appealed. And he said,
well, I'd be or blink,
pinch a change to you.
Ivy would get rid of this
corporate government, Ivo,
create equality, right
ivy, and help the poor.
The poor really get developed here.
I will create effluence, right?
I'd be or created Justin
Affluence Society, right?
And therefore he came up with promises,
what people are looking for.
And then charisma was
attribute it to Fidel Castro.
Uh, I'd off Hitler emerge as
a charismatic leader, right?
A Germany's suffered a humiliating
defeat in the first world war.
Then it was hit with a great depression,
which he Germany even verse then he,
the United States and
then out of Hitler appeal.
Um,
and or he was not quiet as an
attractive personality as Obama was,
you know, quite a ridiculous
guy. But he actually said, well,
I can solve the problems for
you. Right? A defined an anime.
It's, or Jewish conspiracy, CB,
get rid of the Jews and I veal
churning sat around and you know,
we, we have, uh, we,
we all have a new empire and
that it was he capable of it.
This problem.
There was a need in the situation that
people were looking for leadership and
they were looking for a strong leader.
The charismatic leader
and the attribute Id.
This charismatic leadership
feed people to them.
The problem comes when
they cannot deliver a,
certainly Hitler, when the Russian
troops were already fighting,
get out of Berlin, was no
charismatically done any long. Right?
You must hiding in the bunker considering
suicide and he's got his Mo was gone
all together cause he did not deliver.
You did not do the miracles.
Right.
And therefore his charisma was we drove,
um,
now about the followers, right? Uh,
he said the followers of
a charismatic leader, um,
are often often bound together by
emotional ties and they are create an
emotional community with each other.
Uh,
vapor uses these German for
term fatty gemeinschaft too.
They become kind of a community.
There is a real religious leader
with a charismatic appeal.
It creates overs.
Communities of people.
I don't know if any one of you ever
had experiences of some fundamentalist
religious experience. I did when
I was a teenager. There was,
you know, a preacher. Uh, interestingly,
he also did not look charismatic.
He was even not a great speaker.
I don't know how a nurse,
he had these curious charismatic Epi or,
but he did and he did
have an impact on me.
I attribute it to charisma to him and
he's kind of created a community around
himself,
right?
The all were brothers and sisters
together who's kind of believe in the
charismatic guest preacher.
This is very often in kind of sexy area
and fundamentalist religious groups be
Christian or being Muslim,
being evangelical.
There must be people in this
room, right? Who in the,
at least when they were a teenager,
the experience that right.
And you are a teenager and you want
to get out of your family and you are
looking for a new community.
I mean this kind of religious communities
very often offer an alternative one.
Some of you may still be in such
a a community and if you are,
I envy you. I think it is, uh, you know,
as I recall it was a wonderful
experience in some ways,
fairly demand shafto you had your family,
right?
You have your spiritual
family that you belong to.
Does it make any sense of that saying,
I think there must be people I had to
experience that are still experiencing it.
Right?
Um,
so that's what he calls fell gemeinschaft
doing gemeinschaft means community.
Then the mass society
relationships becomes our
relationships like a community.
And indeed,
in even in charismatic political campaign,
you have the sense that
we belonged together.
The coma con calls right there was
fairly gemeinschaft and in civil right
movement right now there's
this charismatic leader,
Martin Luther King, Bobby
Kennedy, right? And, uh,
the whole idea of civil right, and
that'd be cool together, right?
And we go to the south and we demonstrate,
right?
And we demand city will rise
from this bloody raises, right?
That created a sense of
community among people, right?
Who had this belief, uh, on change.
Uh,
uh,
if you want to actually
in such a community,
you have a kind of personal
devotion to the leader,
uh,
and that is a certain degree of an
twosie asthma of what emerges in you,
right? Um, uh,
are bitches of occasionally
coming out of their spare,
uh,
that you are desperate and then
you hope to have some salvation,
uh,
some solution to an end result football
problem by the charismatic leader.
That's how in communism and charismatic
leaders like learning or Mao or Castro
emerged,
right,
is over all societies in deep trouble
after humiliations after wars in Vegan aid
for soc made some major structural
change and then they were looking for a
savior, right? Review,
solve these unresolvable problems
and we lead out to better dies.
Now,
it's also interesting that you know,
in a charismatic communities that is
usually relatively little hierarchy,
not all that much of a
bureaucracy. Um, uh, um, uh,
doors who are actually serving the
charismatic leader usually do not,
uh, yet, uh, uh, salaries or
benefits. It's again, chew, you know,
even for a charismatic political
leaders that they get a whole army of
volunteers because they are so strongly
believe right in the course that they
volunteer that time and money.
Now here comes a, an
entrusting and, uh, uh, uh,
uh,
disturbing proposition that he said about,
but because [inaudible] is
such an extra ordinary form,
it's as it as a system of
charismatic or Traditi,
it is all paused to a rational
and bureaucratic or quality,
right?
Uh,
therefore it is kind of irrational
in the sense of being foreign to all
establish rules because what is a
charismatically that about to change?
And the change means that there will be
new rules of the game and you don't know
exactly what these rules of the Games are.
And this what makes if the charismatic
or quality is a horse system is up or the
eating a high level of
uncertainty to the system.
And now forget about American
politics because in the United States,
um, we clearly have a legal
rational system, right?
That's what characterizes the United
States of America and occasionally the sea
and merging, um, uh,
politicians who actually do implement
some level of change or promise change
whether they can deliver or not will
greatly affect how long v attached
[inaudible] this before.
But from Roosevelt to JFK to
mark and military king, uh,
to, uh, uh, uh, or Obama,
there were politicians
which this charismatic happy
about the system itself was
not charismatic, right? Um,
cat is my health leaders to get elected.
And charisma actually may help a
leader to be able to make some strong.
And the important
changes early on in life.
Those who are critical of president or
Mark Obama usual are critical of him that
he has not moving fast
and forcefully enough,
was not cashing in,
in his charisma early
right in his presidency.
Um, and that is, you know, some
science that in fact, you know,
his charisma charismatic at beer,
uh,
is weakening, right? There
are some people who say, well,
I feel betrayed.
You know,
I was promised change and I
see a lot of politics as usual,
right?
Uh,
so this is of course an inevitable problem
if a leader who has these charismatic
at bill finds itself in the
legal rational authority,
right? That actually it's very
difficult to implement the change.
You want to change the rules,
the law,
alls you have to walk through
Congress to do that, right?
You just cannot declare that from now
on of ours. That is a new game, uh,
rules of the game and that is sounds
very much like politics as usual.
That's a very different,
uh,
from about Lenin or mouse tone there.
Right?
Lenny in and Moussa took,
were not guided by the rules.
They established the rules.
I mean,
mouse or Duke is a particularly
interesting character, right?
He established first I bureaucratic
rule in China and then he launches the
culture revolution,
right?
He launches an anti bureaucratic movement
and the top leader of the bureaucracy
is becoming the major popular leader
of an anti bureaucratic movement.
I mean, this guy was really quite
something quite extraordinary.
And then I may, he did that, you know,
because his charisma was
weakened by the 1960s first.
He promised greatly four of our,
you know,
in no time they will catch up and
we'd be look like the United States.
And what happened with the
Greek lead for Var disaster,
people were starving to death.
So he was not delivering the miracle.
So what does he does next?
He shows us here is a real change,
the rules of the game.
He launches the culture
revolution and he's,
he suddenly becomes the leader
of people who actually should be,
or pausing Kim, uh, you know,
he is generating this kind of
miracles, you know, the last miracle,
but he's driving to January at all age
that he goes rimming in the young chair
river. You see, you think
I'm old and I'm dying. No,
I'm super human. I still
can serve him. Alright.
This is the kind of, you
know, trying to rescue, right?
You are charismatic Aptio and it
is about to be taken away from you.
But on the whole,
as we see as they established these
charismatic leaders established as
charismatic system, they can
change the rules. And you know,
if you look at Chinese
history every five years,
everything is completely
different, right? Um, uh,
first a hundred flowers,
four ish.
We all that every body will then,
you know, greatly for them. You know,
cultural revolution.
He is changing the rules all the time.
This is an unpredictable environment.
Candle economies work in this unpacking
unpredictable environment. No,
it cannot.
The same goes for the Nazis.
And the same goes for the Stalinists.
Right? It was unpredictable.
Environment was not good for business.
Business needs a predictable environment,
right?
It needs to rule of law.
That's why capital is
business at least, uh, lives,
legal,
rational or authority.
They don't necessarily lie
democratic system, right?
Capitalism can leave nicely
with authoritarian figures
and capitalist to love
the peanut chair, right?
Uh, God, you know,
peanut share was, you know, reasonable,
illegal Ashman authority. I mean,
at the beginning, you know, he
was killing people like crazy,
but then he established a
reasonably predictable system
and capitalist loved it.
And for the vile,
you know,
the Chilean economy partially had
wise by Milton Friedman, you know,
both Steve.
So I mean,
about capitalism really wants is a
predictable environment. And in many ways,
you know,
democracy is not all that good for the
predictable environment because every
fourth year we go to the pools and then
we elect other people and then they come
up with other ideas. And this is
a bit of a mess. So in reality,
I would almost say that a good free
market economy lavs rule of law,
Evita kind of authoritarian and a
longstanding policy because the ability,
they don't like this big changes
right in the political system.
Uh, well, um, no, and charisma
is that evolutionary force.
This is very important.
I think we were first before for
making some very specific argument.
He said it is all of us in
traditional historic barriers, right?
Traditional Authority,
when charisma is the great
should rally for us. So in fact,
in a modern legal, rational
authority, it is not so much charisma,
which cat is the change through.
It is technical innovation and it is
a kind of routine and boring elections
every four years,
which brings changes by gradually and
incrementally the big changes occurring
from one type of traditional authority
to another type of authority.
And in order to change the value system
of one type of tradition to another type
of tradition that's venue
neath charismatic leaders.
So he said,
I bureaucratic rationalization ears
to major it evolutionarily for us.
But you know, in a bureaucratic
system like what we have,
it is a reality.
A revolution from the south.
It is coming from technological change.
We have an evolution or yes,
I'm in the first time when I heard
that his staff like Internet is,
was uh, uh, an email.
It was 1976 and now I'm
an inter, you know, uh,
uh, email, uh, at that addict
does many of, you know,
you sent me an email and occasional in
five minutes you get an answer from me
because I always checking my email
like crazy. This was all I knew.
All this was coming from the outside.
Now a charisma.
On the other hand, this is very
insightful, very important.
It is revolution from within,
but charisma is doing is changing
the value systems in you, right?
That's what charismatic leaders do achieve
to persuade you that you have to have
a different kind of value system.
And that's why I think charismatic leader,
she does play a role not only
in traditional societies,
but you know,
charismatic leaders in a legal,
rational authority do play a role
to change people's value systems,
uh, in substantial ways. Again,
we discussed that in discussion section
as those who are not in my discussion
section. Just uh, let me involve
the civil right movement, right?
The civil right movement in 10 years in
the United States produced the change in
value systems,
our attitudes to race relationships
and gender relationships,
which otherwise would have
taken a hundred years, right?
It happened in 10 short years that we
completely resold a race and gender
relationships in this country, right? Uh,
and it's to a large extent the mended,
right?
Charismatic leaders,
it demanded, right? Uh,
Martin Luther King, right?
Uh, who had a dream right,
about the society where there can be a
different type of value system and in no
time, I mean, you were too young to
experience that, but your balance and but,
and six billions and talk to
them, they will tell you, right?
How fundamentally their word outlook and
looking at a person of another race or
how they begin to cheat a villain in
their family or girls in the family.
How radically change almost instantly,
right?
Because it was a change from the thing,
That's what charismatic
revolution is all about.
Um, and well, this is uh, uh,
of course, uh, uh, has
everything to do against routine.
Charismatic is not doing
things as they used to be.
That's why it is the opposite,
right? Of One type of traditionalism.
And the problem is what happens in the
charismatic leader disappears and die.
So that's when we have the problem.
How can the charismatic leader
be replaced as a very big issue?
And there are different
matters of succession.
And let me just walk
you through all of this.
It's not fight on interesting.
Again, be sure search,
it can be biased about it.
He Shun.
It can be designation
by the origin or leader.
It can be designation by a staff,
which is particularly qualified to decide
who is the next charismatic leader.
There'll be loud. The issue is how
can you maintain a charismatic,
the system Goin gon it can be had at that
Terry that's some had that they on is
established and it can be office charisma.
The office itself.
Get Kelly charisma.
Now,
let me just briefly talk to
each one of these church.
Um,
the best example is how
you found the Dalai Lama,
right?
It happens to US church.
The lie alarm or dies,
you know that the da Lai
Lama is reincarnated.
So you send out to people and looking
for the child who is the become nation of
the Da Lai Lama.
There must be just one child who is
the incarnation of the Da Lai Lama.
Then you have experts who can tell,
go around and then they find this child.
This is the new Dalai Lama.
And then if you'll be brought up
and will become the Dalai Lama,
and of course we'll have a greed deal.
Uh,
af charisma. You can't
see it. The barracks,
uh,
the Da Lai Lama does heck a
lot of galleries right now
other than you believe in
reincarnation or not? That's
another story. Uh, uh,
probably most people in this
room do not believe in it,
but if you do not believe it,
it even more miraculous why the Dalai
Lama has this white extra ordinary care is
not,
there are people who just get wired if
they can get near to the Dalai Lama.
I had a student in Taiwan who actually
turned into a boat his and became a great
follower of the Dalai Lama.
He got a phd from Ucla.
What he's following, whatever
the da Lai Lama, who was his,
all of us there because he has
these charisms, his charisma,
his attribute it to him,
right?
He was found in the right way and he was
established as a charismatic leader can
happen through revelation.
Revelation actually means that,
uh,
there are some people who believed to
have some kind of access to some divine
authority.
Who can that clear that this is a person
who is the next scan asthmatic leader?
Well,
I don't think in contemporary reverse
revelation is all that much though were,
I mean, newspapers do it for you, right?
The newspapers do create
charismatic leaders for you.
They attach charismatic,
they build up.
The charismatic powers are for half a
person in the media does it for you and
certainly their charisma
attribute it to um,
a rock stars, rock stars
to have charisma, right,
is created through the media. The
media has the oral call, right?
He knows who the grade
guys are and whom you,
you'll have to get absolutely the ABS
excited when you get to the accounts
shirt. Now that can be a
designation by the origin or leader.
Uh,
if the charismatic leader is dying,
then the charismatic leader has a
problem to find a successor that very
difficult to do because charismatic
leaders are bloody scared that if they
designate a leader,
then they will be poisoned or merge.
Uh, the new leader wants
to take it over to often.
Very often we see charismatic leaders
designating leaders and then murdered in
them.
That's a long history in human guide.
But you know,
an interesting example was that styling
tried to build up his charisma by
thinking a testimonial off
[inaudible] learning ambitious.
You normally 11 said that stallion,
there'll be the successor.
This was all lie landing in.
Actually the slight, uh, uh,
uh, starting a great deal and was
very reluctant to name a successor,
but he forged his letter and try to save
l I inherited the charisma and he had a
lot of problems actually to
establish his charisma. Eventually.
In fact,
during the Second World War,
he managed where merged as a charismatic
leader and not in only in the Soviet
Union,
but even in the vest.
There's a lot of people in
the United States as a, the,
the Soviet Army defeated the Germans
first in Moscow and then of course in
styling Grad that they begin to see
starting as a great leader, right?
As a charismatic Greek leader,
we probably had nothing to do with
the success of the Red Army now,
or it can be designated
by a qualified staff. Uh,
this is the way half, for
instance, the poop is being,
uh,
selected and the boob thus have
lie the charismatic authority.
If you are all man catalytic,
you know that the pope
has some access to God,
what you ordinarily Roman
Catholics do not have and how is,
but it's going one from
bomb pop to the next.
The character of the book will
matter, right? There are some more,
you know,
charming more passwords if books when we,
you'll see more charismatic leaders
that are other groups who are more like
middle Kratz but never the less,
even the bureaucratic kind of Forbes art
assume to be charismatic and they are
Sellek then,
uh,
by a designated staff that is a
certain set of archbishop's men.
One Paul dies, they gather together in
Rome and they cannot leave, you know,
the room until they agree
the achieve their consensus.
Who is the other person who will have
dispatch shoddy relationship to God?
All right. Uh, that is
also had other attitude,
that charisma that you try to pass
a charisma on to your children.
Very hard to do a North Skoda
is trying to do that, right?
Himi was shown passed, uh, uh, his, uh,
charisma onto Kim Jung Il,
which is an absolutely ridiculous guy.
But nevertheless,
you know, somehow, yeah,
it looks like you know that in Korea he
does have some kind of get is matic at
bill.
So I mean this is not totally impossible.
I mean that's a bad idea.
You know,
if you are charismatic leader to
brass charisma on the spree buying,
not the office got his Ma,
this is very important in combines
of an office is supposed to have some
charismatic depending on the office,
but the office of the book of course
it's supposed to have charisma,
but we actually do use this very often.
We do barely into your aunt to for
you we call this leadership right?
That we expect people in put us in
position of certain authorities to offer
leadership to have vision.
Right?
And this is an a kind of a charisma
which goals, uh, via with the office.
And you know, I have been
department chair, uh,
quite a few times and uh,
it's so interesting moving into the
position of department chair and more
meaning out of it.
But your relationship to your
college change agreed there.
You know when you are the pen,
the and chair that is southern is Sammy
charisma is attribute it to you right
now. You are a support to offer some
kind of leadership annual, I believe,
to be able to bring in songs
change. I just remember, you know,
one of the institutions and I was an
incoming outside share our people say,
ah, you came in life fresh
air early in two years time.
It was all gone. I was not Rochelle.
I was a little tee in, you know,
I was operating, you know, bureaucracy,
massaging the mirror accuracy to get
the exam. My charisma was all God.
But there is, right. I think it's
a very American thing, right?
That you attach an expectations
to an incumbents of the office,
that it can actually carry out
change, bringing fresh air, right.
To have a vision and to do these
better than it was done before. Okay.
That's about charisma.
Thank you.